foreign
goodbye from the last train out of Leeds
for some it was a desperate scramble to
get home
making it on board just seconds before
departure
for others who miss the trains Christmas
plans plunged into doubt
for now I'm actually stuck so I have to
change my plan right now because I have
to take a bus instead to go to London I
was planning to go to Manchester to be
honest and then we have to restrict our
traveling times and do work at
wetherspoons he's been dead I was trying
to get back to geisley which is where I
live
um
yeah but to be honest I'm I'm fully in
support of the of the Striking male
workers I think they've had a really
rough deal over the years
when the Clock Struck three most trains
across the UK were parked as rail
workers started yet another flurry of
strike action
but they weren't the only ones border
four staff refusing to work until the
year is out
[Applause]
Highway workers staying away from busy
motorways and Royal Mail employees
scaling back deliveries at their busiest
time of year there's no denying the
strikes across all sectors in the days
leading up to Christmas Eve have been
disruptive lives put on hold people
changing plans at the last minute but in
the 24 hours leading up to the big day
the impact seems Limited
our journey hasn't been impacted today
so far fingers crossed and we're just a
few minutes delayed this is not the
exact time I would have loved to travel
I would have loved to travel later in
the afternoon but I couldn't get a train
so I've had to come in start my journey
earlier so the touring tickets have sold
out now my dad has to be inconvenient to
pick me up from Leeds instead of walking
to to my home from Lomo Christmas is of
course a time for coming together but as
it stands there's no sign of
reconciliation between unions and their
opposites we're available actually
immediately after Christmas prepared to
put the time and effort in to to thrash
out an agreement if we can't reach an
agreement then there will be further
strikes in the new year and we will have
to rebalot our members
as the disputes remain unsolved more
disruption awaits across both public and
private sectors people clearly have
planned and adapted to cope for the rest
of this year but further walkouts in
2023 could test the patience of many
intima Rashid Sky News Birmingham